Mariah Mitchell whose first name is
spelled like mine ma RI a but it's
pronounced mariah and not maria is the
first recognized female astronomer in
america and was the first woman elected
unanimously to the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences in 1831 when she was
still a teenager obsessed with
stargazing she heard that the King of
Denmark had offered a gold medal valued
at twenty ducats which was a lot of
money at the time - the first person to
discover a telescopic comet it took her
16 years to master the science and the
craft of observation but she did become
the first person and see 1847 t1 was
known for a hundred years as Miss
Mitchell's Comet later when she was
hired to teach astronomy advanced to
newly established Vassar College she was
the first woman on the faculty and
according to the official handbook of
college rules female students were not
allowed to go outside after dark this
was a problem for the study of astronomy
Mitchell fought tirelessly to overturn
not just this but many other rules based
on antiquated gender norms that held
back women in science later she was
hired as the first woman to perform a
non-domestic specialized skill for the
US federal government she was paid $300
a year for her job as a computer of
Venus for the United States nautical
almanac it was a very very
mathematically rigorous job that
required her to perform very complex
calculations that would predict the
position of Venus in the sky for years
to come and in the days before GPS and
satellites this is how sailors all over
the world navigated the oceans by the
time she was 14 Mitchell had reached
celebrity status as one of the most
famous women in the world which is a
remarkable feat for a scientist even
today we don't have many celebrity
scientists but she was most beloved for
her extraordinary generosity of spirit
that went along with her genius she
didn't much care for the accolades and
the recognition and the celebrity but
she went
a way to mentor and help cultivate the
talents of women and science which
required that she overcame her painful
shyness in order to be a public speaker
and a public figure and a role model and
an educator which she continued to be
she continued to teach right up until
her death